foreign
ERS of Ramsay Solutions broadcasting
from the PODS moving and storage Studios
it's the Ramsay show where we help
people build wealth do work that they
love and create actual amazing
relationships I'm your host Dave Ramsey
my co-host today Ramsey personality the
ever popular Jade warshaw is with me
we'll be here answering your questions
about your life and your money
translation we're going to talk about
you right in front of you open phones at
triple eight eight two five five two two
five that's eight eight two five five
two two five Giancarlo starts off this
hour in Orlando hey Giancarlo how are
you
Hi how are you better than I deserve
what's up
oh my gosh uh first of all thank you
again for taking the call I've been
listening show for about two weeks man
since I've been a life changing for me
wow so here's my situation
um I'm 37 years old I make uh about 130k
a year
I own two houses one for rental property
which I get uh about 1500 of profit and
I have another mortgage which I just got
into a year ago when I moved to Orlando
and I paid 2500 on it
um I have a car payment of 600 a month
uh and I still owe thirty thousand
dollars on it uh I have solar panels
that I bought in the first home for
forty thousand dollars and the interest
of this is of five percent and then I
have a student loan uh that which is 30k
so uh before you scream I mean also I've
always been um I've had that uh habits
with money
um thank God thank God that I made a
good I met a good woman she helped me
safe right now we have about 30k in
savings and 25k and 401K so we were
thinking about because we're currently
gonna be planning on moving back to New
Jersey and we were thinking about buying
a house
my gut feeling is now that I want to get
out of debt yeah so um
you know what's my best
steps that I can take well thank you for
being a new listener we're honored to
have you here we appreciate it so you're
thinking about moving to New Jersey
and um and marrying this girl I guess
oh we're married already oh you're
married already good okay everybody took
a long a long time for me to get me up
to Spanish good money but I had bad
habits with good money I understand
you're doing you're doing okay and so
thank you for again for hanging out with
us and you're going to move to New
Jersey when
uh the end of October
okay all right what do you do for a
living
I work in I.T okay which is good good
all right so the premise of everything
that Jade and I and the rest of the
Ramsey people around here do is based on
the simple formula that says okay what
is the shortest fastest
safest right way between Where You Are
and becoming wealthy
okay
so in other words we're trying to figure
out okay what's efficient and part of
efficiency is lowering risk
does that make sense
yeah so let me Define risk for you as a
guy who owns a whole bunch of rental
property and I have for gosh going on
for 50 years now I've almost been a
landlord 50 years that's scary so
um but the uh uh 40 anyway so the uh uh
the risk is I have a rental house in
Orlando and I live in New Jersey that's
risk
it's also known as a pain in the butt
that makes sense
yeah so I'm going to always move you and
I I like real estate I like what you're
thinking about real estate and you've
obviously been thinking about money
stuff and that's what led you to find us
but also LED you to do some of the other
stuff you've done so you're you know you
might be bad with money in your own mind
or or based on what you've heard in the
last two weeks but I think you're a guy
who thinks about this stuff a lot and so
um it's going to lead me to sell both
houses when I move to New Jersey
and maybe the thirty thousand dollar car
and get a good start for a good fresh
start because I know that I know for
sure having walked the path with
millions of people that the fastest way
for you to become wealthy is to get
control of your hundred thirty thousand
dollar income and quit giving it all to
everybody else
how does that hit you I I I hear you
soaking it in Giancarlo I am I am I'm
thinking about it so you're saying
my the best decision that I can make is
uh sell both my houses New Jersey think
about it he's trying to get you to where
you have peace so if you already know
that you want to get a house in New
Jersey let's clear the first two out how
much do you think that you would clear
if you were to sell both of those homes
I can probably buy a house cash
look at that at your age you own a cash
house in New Jersey making 130. come on
plus you didn't even tell me her income
what's her income
you know she uh she's a stay-at-home
okay so four yeah so 130 000 income no
house payment oh we got rid of the car
payment yeah that's 600 and gosh do you
have any debt left when we do all that
uh I don't know if I mentioned before my
student that is about 30k okay all right
but you got you've got that money I mean
if you guys sell this car yeah you've
got that in the bank sell the car you've
got get you a little something to get
around in that leaves you some money to
clear out a good portion of the student
loans
if not all of it he's got 30 000 of
those then you've got the solar panels
but solar panels are going to be covered
in the sale of the house they're lean on
the property okay there you go that I
mean look think about that that's
amazing
and you don't now you don't have a house
payment you don't have a car payment
you're going to knock out those student
loans in two seconds and then what I
want you to do is save your old house
payments save your old car payment and
save anything else you can squeeze out
of your budget and pay cash for your
next rental
in about four years
okay and then you know what happened and
then when you have a paid four house and
a paid for a rental and no debt At All
by the way your income will go up during
that four years too and so during all of
that time then you're going to see
you're gonna be sitting on 200 000
income in five years with no payments
and uh not to mention your rental income
and then the next one you pay cash for
will come even quicker and the next one
will come even quicker you know how I
know that is because I did it
the first one is the hardest to pay cash
for but every time after that it gives
you more money to build you get a
snowball rolling in your favor now
the wheels are turning the wheels are
turning the wheels are turning you know
it's funny uh Giancarlo sometimes when
we've made bad mistakes with money it's
like you do one thing and it triggers
this domino effect of bad decisions but
conversely if you start making the right
decisions you start doing the right
things it triggers that same domino
effect of of good things paying off your
debt being able to do the things that
you want to do and so this is an
exciting day in my opinion yeah so what
what were what were really challenging
with you with is you need to come up
with a philosophy of handling money that
is going to because you become wealthy
with the least risk the fastest
and by the way the fastest is with the
least risk best way to get rich quick
Get Rich slow
that's the fastest way to get rich and
keep it
yeah hang on we're going to send you a
copy of the book The Total Money
Makeover it's up 10 million people do
this this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees ever
things back back there why
their wash and guarantee and
hands-free see whyblinds.com is the
number one online retailer of custom
window coverings go to blinds.com now
and save 45 off selected products visit
blinds.com today for more info
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
Jade Washington Ramsay personality is my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
today's question of the day is sponsored
by neighborly your hub for Home Services
if you own rental property neighbors
local rear until Real Property
Management offices can manage them and
help you optimize your Roi and peace of
mind visit neighborly.com to schedule a
consultation with Real Property
Management Pros near you today's
question comes from Jenny in Arkansas
she says if I'm on baby step three do I
still need baby step one of one thousand
dollars or does that become part of the
fully funded emergency fund I assume
it's one pot of money now but I didn't
know if I should still keep that
separate that's an interesting question
I mean yeah the thousand dollars rolls
into your three to six months of savings
yeah it disappears it disappears and all
of that you're keeping ideally in an
hysa like a high yield savings account
if you wanted to
have a little bit of cash and you're
safe at home I guess I'm not mad at that
but I'd keep it all in one spot I
personally Dave like to keep my money
to where it's kind of it's liquid but I
can't just easy get easily get to it
willy-nilly so I'm not keeping it in my
sock drawer
um I'm not keeping it as part of my
checking account I want to put it
somewhere
where it's separate it's over there you
need to think about it before you pull
from it because some people strong
emergency fund does not need to have
your ATM attached okay that's right and
yes because some of these hysas they'll
give you the option Dave to put a debit
card with it just say no nope just say
no because trust me I I've learned the
hard way
is not an emergency that's right by
definition that's right definition if
you want to save up and buy a couch
that's fine but by definition a couch on
sale or anything else you decide to
impulse your little butt on okay is not
an emergency and so atming and debit
carding away your emergency fund's a
dumb idea that's a different idea
different point than her question her
question is the thousand dollars rolls
in it's all one it's all one thing maybe
step one disappears when you get to
three that's right it rolls in two three
so I don't have a separate one thousand
dollars other than I carry a redneck
emergency phone in my front pocket
that's what I'm saying 100 bills I carry
100 bills there but that's true Dave
don't be telling folks you got hundreds
in your pockets well I got stuff on the
other pocket okay just checking just
I think I think we got it
covered we're all right we're in good
shape open phones at triple eight eight
two five five I don't want to mess with
YouTube
um is in New York City hey Tom how are
you
I'm great thanks so much for taking the
call I really appreciate it sure what's
up
so here I know you had a lot of calls to
get too so I'll cut to the point so
about a year ago my mother needed a
little bit of money to help purchase a
home so I took money against my 401k to
lend her some money fifty thousand
dollars with the Proviso being that when
she sold another apartment shoe to repay
me
um I've decided that since it's my
mother I changed my mind that I don't
want the money back I'm just gifting her
that money
um I still owe about thirty five
thousand dollars on my 401k loan um the
question I have for you is
so at the time I took the loan the bank
interest rates that I was earning I was
only earning about one percent right so
I've got about 150 000 in cash earning
five percent in just the high yield
savings account so I could of course
just pay off that 401k loan tomorrow if
I wanted to but here's the thing I'm
only paying the loan at 3.25 and as you
know I'm actually paying myself back I'm
not paying any interest to a lending
institution so I'm trying to decide if
it makes more sense
to just keep paying it down and pay that
35 000 off you know what happens here
you know what happens 90 of the years
that follow a bear Market in the stock
market
what we have a recession no we have a
bull market
oh there you go okay
and the two if you'll go back and look
at your look at your stock market Trend
histories you'll see that uh almost
every time following a bear Market we
see a 15 to a 25 rate of return the year
following you're going to miss all of
that
because you're paying yourself five
percent you're trying to get fancy
right okay never borrow on your 401k
never use borrowed money on your 401k to
try to build wealth and never try to
Arbitrage the money on your 401k to make
a spread in other words which is what
you're talking about all of these things
this is your nickeling and diming you're
stepping over dollars picking up nickels
okay well let me throw one other caveat
at you to just see if it changes
anything so I only have about 10 more
payments on my mortgage on my apartment
but I do need to sell it and upgrade to
a larger space because I have a child
now so I am trying to stockpile cash for
the down payment so does that change the
equation at all and that I want to have
as much as positives I wouldn't tell you
to borrow on your 401k to buy your new
apartment and essentially it's the same
thing if you don't pay it off
okay I'm still because I'm still paying
down alone
yeah in other words if you don't pay
this loan off
so that you can put money down more
money down on the new apartment which is
your question that I understand you're
right
correct that has the same effect on your
finances as if you had borrowed on your
401k to put more money down on your new
apartment
you follow me okay I understand yeah I
do I do follow you from a balance sheet
perspective so yeah no it does not
change the equation as a matter of fact
it puts more pressure on the answer for
you to do it the way we said clean this
up and quit trying to borrow your way
into wealth it doesn't work
okay gotcha okay thank you thanks for
calling man we appreciate it sorry hit
the button real quick I'm out of
practice I don't know Dave I feel like
that I feel like you had a little a
little Snappy on that no I didn't mean
to I'm just out of practice I'm out of
practice being nice
that's pretty nice I felt
it did you see a little bit okay
I'm here for it Arya yes good okay I'm
glad well word is while I were gone I
was gone that you were the one doing
that so what do I know look they're
gonna I'll let you you be the pit bull
today and I'm just here I'll just I'm
not I'm not the Pitbull
yeah you're in charge you're in charge
you you and Rachel all right if we
didn't think you were in charge you're
in charge Roslyn's with us in Kansas
City hi Rosalind what's up
hi thanks for taking my call I have a
question I have we don't have any debt
except for the house I am starting a
full-time job teaching next month and my
husband wants to put everything just max
everything we can for retirement
um and I would like to take whatever I
take home to put towards paying off our
house we have a 2.25 15-year fixed with
about 227 000 left on it
um and we've been using I've been
subbing and we've been using subbing
money for travel so he'd rather use what
I come home we have three kids out of
state so he's rather use my come take
home money to travel and
um but I want to try and put a percent
towards the house paying down the house
where he says our interest rate is so
low that we don't need to do that and
we'd rather invest when you say that he
wants to max out retirement is that does
that exceed your 15 percent
um I haven't been working full-time no
I've been a stay-at-home mom
um and so he wants me to catch up and
his biggest thing is retirement he
doesn't think we can retire unless I'm
working full-time we don't need the
money to live how old are y'all how old
are y'all 50 and 52. so he's not
concerned about enough enough about
retirement to quit traveling today right
because that's my extra money right so
no it's not extra money I mean it's all
money it's all money and it's all in you
in one pile and the two of you own it
you're 50 years old yes okay and you're
traveling is fine but when you have our
money when you separate it so that you
get to do what you want to do that's
called spoiled and so
um no that's not a plan so you know what
we're going to tell you your whole
household income you take your whole
household income times .15 15
that much should be going into
retirement any money that's left over in
your budget above 15 percent going into
retirement should go to paying off your
house extra if there's any left after
you travel
but 15
ought to be going into retirement right
now not 20 percent that's right maxed
out not two percent and quit separating
your income it's one pile of income
and attack your attack your retirement
with that 15 then pay on the house if
there's money left after travel and
that'll get that'll address the travel
issue this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
all right
it's a competitive home buying Market
but there's a way you can get an edge
Churchill Mortgage works with you to
understand your budget and your goals
and the Churchill Mortgage home buyer
Edge offers you fast pre-approval and a
secured interest rate plus Churchill has
bumped up their seller guarantee to ten
thousand dollars giving your offer the
best chance of being accepted and
helping you win in today's market go to
churchillmortgage.com today to learn
more
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
personality is my co-host today thank
you for joining us America we're so glad
you're here open phones at triple eight
eight two five five two two five Phillip
is with us in Pittsburgh hi Philip
welcome to the Ramsey Show
hey Dave how you doing better than I
deserve what's up
um well um I had a question my wife and
I have been on big step two for a while
um I only make about 50 to 55 000 a year
and uh I've been working at my dad's
shop he he's been here for about 40
years or so and he's been been talking
about wanting to retire in the next year
or two and
was wondering if I wanted to take over
like buy it and take over but I'm not
100 sure if
that's the right move forward for me uh
or if I should
consider something else
um
I've never really considered myself a
business person never really had a dream
of taking over I just kind of worked
here as a lot of repair technician for
most of my life so
I
kind of hoping to
get my income up a little more and I
didn't know if I should
somehow figure out how to take over and
run the shop or if I should
consider something else and I just
wanting to get your advice on the in the
situation
so it's an auto repair shop and you're
an auto repair technician and he owns
the shop
and how many bays how many bays is it
so about three Bay and how many uh
technicians
uh it's just me and Dad does some some
of the repair work on the when he's not
running the office and we have one other
guy that does body work but he doesn't
really do technician stuff
so your dad does not turn wrenches
anymore
um sometimes but yeah not not full-time
just sometimes when we get a little
behind yeah and how long have you been
doing this
I've been here off and on for the last
20 25 years
just kind of grew up next to it and
worked here as a kid growing up
[Music]
are you scared of it or you don't want
to do it
um
I'm not uh very good at
like making decisions and being the
final authority of things so I didn't
think running it would be a good thing
but I don't also don't know if that's
something I can learn to make it
profitable
um
so it's kind of both I guess
hmm
how old are you
I'm 36.
you make decisions working on the cars
every day
yeah but I just kind of check them over
and see what's wrong and let him call
the customer and decide what they want
to do with it so
if you were to take this business if you
were to take this business on would you
kind of do the way your dad does where
you're just doing the the administrative
part or would you try to juggle both and
do that while you're also working on
vehicles
well that's I'm not sure I I enjoy the
uh working on the cars yeah I can tell
so if if I went into the you have any
idea what kind of profit he's making
not for sure we've we've never really
talked about in specific numbers or
anything so I don't really know
okay I know we're really busy and have
lots of lots of cars here but of course
the numbers I don't know
so you're not even if you wanted to buy
the business you're not sure what it
would take or what the what the deal
would look like
right
how old's your dad
is 68. all right
okay so
um well let's run a couple of scenarios
down
um it doesn't sound like you want to run
this business
uh I mean nothing nothing in this
conversation screams
Philip owns and runs a business
nothing here uh you don't want to you
don't feel up to it it intimidates you
uh the idea of having to do what he does
every day sounds like hell to you
yeah okay
so you don't want to run this business
sir I mean I'm just saying back to you
what you said
I agree I don't think it doesn't make
sense based off of what you've said to
earn to possibly earn a little bit more
and take on responsibilities that you
don't want yeah I just now have you got
certifications
I don't uh maybe because I grew up
working here so I mean I never needed
them
um because he's either going to sell
this or close it if you don't buy it
right he's 68 there's an end to this
right you're not going to be doing what
you do in that bay exactly the way you
do it 10 years from today zero chance
the right way to talk to him about it or
see what how to move forward if I don't
take it over
well the way forward is you're going to
be working for somebody else and you're
gonna have to go get some certifications
to do that probably
yeah
to prove that you know what we what you
and I know that you know you know it but
you're going to be able to prove it to
work in a dealership or work in a com
you know a more certified shop situation
right am I wrong yeah yeah no yeah
you're right yeah
yeah so um you know and
I don't know I I have no idea I I but I
I can't think that you're going to be
happy
doing a bunch of stuff you don't want to
do just for some more money
yeah even if it doubled your income it
doesn't make it fun that's right
right yeah
so I mean the idea of dealing with the
customers and you know and I know that a
percentage of them are crazy
especially when their car is broken down
it's like having a root canal nobody's
happy right and so um dentists and car
repair people they deal with unhappy
people all day and so um you know it's
uh you don't you don't want to deal with
the people's side of this you like you
like making the car run not the business
but are you feeling any pressure to keep
this business going like it's your dad
your dad dad wants him to do it keep it
in in the family is that what it is yeah
yeah he said that he would like to keep
it in the family which and there's no
one else that's like hey I'm I'm in
management I'm I'd love to be part of
this that's part of the family
no no none of my siblings have shown
really any interest of wanting to take
it over yeah so you're going to be
working for the person that buys it or
you're going to be working for someone
else when it closes
yeah or you're gonna buy it so change is
in your future Phillip I just don't know
what the change is going to look like
and um a good idea is to try to decide
in advance which change you want
and cause that change to happen rather
than let this whole thing happen to you
so sitting down talking to your dad dad
I love you and it's been fun doing all
this together all these years I have I
would get no joy I would get sheer
Terror I would get pain I would get
ulcers from trying to do what you do
every day I don't want to do that even
for more money and the fact that you
love me enough to want to offer this to
me is very kind thanks Dad I appreciate
you I appreciate getting to work with
you all these years and I'll work with
you as long as you want to keep running
it but
I'm not your buyer because I don't want
to run a business it's not my goal even
if he even if
even if someone to do day-to-day tasks
it I still don't think that'd be good
because he'd still have to have some you
know I mean you still have to have
involvement yeah in that part of it when
you're when you run a business it's
different than working on a car yeah and
when you run a business it's different
than installing heat and air yeah when
you run a business it's different than
painting all different skills man so if
you're a really great painter and you
decide your own business for yourself
well now you do accounting and you do
marketing and you do personnel and HR
and you do uh deal with bankers and you
deal with the customers and you deal
with all their crap and you deal when
they're happy and when they're not happy
and you do you make all that stuff when
you're running a business it's different
than doing the task that the business
does and so
um oftentimes people become accidental
entrepreneurs that's right because their
business grow you know the need for
their thing they're good at in his case
working on a car is so strong and we do
need great people working on cars right
um we all we all definitely need great
people working on but the need is so
strong that you confuse that with
running the skills the skills to work on
a car are different than the skills to
run a business that's right and Philip
has recognized that and it's wisdom that
is wisdom yeah he's gonna have to find a
new job though yeah sad it's transition
though one thing you can count on
change this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
Jade wash all Ramsey personality is my
co-host today thank you for joining us
America open phones at triple eight
eight two five five two two five Cody is
with us in Dallas hi Cody welcome to the
Ramsey Show
hey Dave how are you better than I
deserve what's up
hey uh so my wife and I we started the
baby steps uh here just a couple weeks
ago and uh we're on baby step two we got
our thousand dollars saved
um but uh now we're the only debt
outside of our house that we have are
our two cars and so
um one car is worth twenty four thousand
and the other car is worth sixteen
thousand
um and so uh we are looking to get rid
of the car that's worth twenty four
thousand
um and so I've kind of shopped around uh
just to see uh what people would offer
and everything
um and some dealers are coming back you
know saying that they'll give us you
know 18 to 19 000 for it but I also
looked on Edmonds and Kelly Blue Book to
see uh what it was self or privately and
that's saying it would sell around
twenty four thousand so it would
basically break even so you oh you owe
24 on it
yes sir who do you owe the money to
um it is a a bank uh Huntington bank or
something like that oh is it a local
bank
uh no sir okay it's one of those uh a
national online banking yeah okay
well I would um so I'm sorry no go ahead
and say what you were going to say
finisher oh I was just gonna say
um so how do you sell the private or the
car privately if you still owe on it
the um obvious well I think Texas is a
title State and the bank is holding your
title does that sound right
yes sir okay and in order for them to
release the title they need twenty four
thousand dollars so Tennessee is the
same way so when I sell a car if I sold
a car with debt here or bought a car
with that here as an example uh from an
individual I would get a bill of sale
from them the keys to the car and the
car
I would give them the check for the car
they would send the check to the D to
the bank and pay the loan off the bank
would send the title to them and then
they would bring me the title that might
take a few weeks
and so notify Huntington bank and find
out how long it's going to take to get
your title from payoff
okay
and then uh like so if I whenever I do
find a seller for it or something a
buyer um or a buyer that's right my bad
um basically just kind of be upfront
with them about that you know saying hey
you know I still uh you know own this
car yeah I got to get the title and the
way I get the title is I pay the loan
off the way I pay the loan off is you
pay me and you get a bill of sale and
you get the car
so and that's done all the time there's
nothing sketchy about that at all I've
bought cars from people that way that it
took me a while to get the title from
them I bought an old Jeep not long ago
and um took a little while to get the
title on the thing and um because the
guy had to go down to the bank I mean in
the old days the bank was in your
neighborhood and you'd both go down to
the bank and they'd pull the title out
of the file and put it on the table
right in front of both of you and you do
the transfer all at once right but
nowadays the bank is freaking online and
some you know uh other other end of the
country or something and it may take and
they and you know it sounds like this is
a a bank that does a lot of auto dealer
lending maybe even subprime lending and
so it they got probably a bunch of
titles it's probably going to take them
a little while so I would talk to them
about how cumbersome the process is so
you can be upfront with your buyer some
buyers will get nervous and not want to
do this
okay
but for six thousand dollars come on I'm
going to the trouble
oh yeah absolutely that's that's exactly
what you know we're wanting to do yeah
there's no way that we want to pay that
six thousand if we don't have to so you
don't have to not because of this anyway
now what kind of car is it uh so it is a
uh a 2021 Chevy Malibu okay that Coral
cell
yeah that's cool you can sell that car
that's not you know it's not not some
kind of weird thing or something I mean
that's what I was asking about now Dave
you said in a title State that's the way
you would do that's the only way I know
to do it is there another one I don't
know I mean there are other situations
where the title is done differently okay
and I don't I don't know how to process
it there because I've never done it okay
but I've done the I actually did buy a
car in Texas come to think of it a long
time ago and um had it brought to
Tennessee in the same situation the cow
was in financial trouble and I bought
his car long long time ago and uh in
another life but yeah yeah that's
exactly but but
um and I actually I think that's the way
it happens in almost okay but I think
there might you know I always leave room
for stuff I don't know which is like
California everything I don't know it's
in California so Heather is in Honolulu
and I don't know anything there either
hi Heather how are you
hey Dave hi Jade how you guys doing good
how can we help
um okay I wrote some things down so I'm
taking a four thousand dollar pay cut
um we made our HELOC larger to
consolidate everything to compensate for
the hangar and then I started
obsessively listening to the show
um my question is we have equity in our
home and we're thinking about selling
our house moving into a house that my
husband and brother-in-law have
inherited that just it's fair uh it's
closer closer to town and work and
school
um you know I just are we doing the
right thing by selling our house that we
have now we have two empty bedrooms
because I had five I have five kids but
three of them are older
um and don't live with us anymore won't
you sell the house that they own
together
I'm sorry what was that why don't you'll
sell the house down together
there is another house on the property
so it's two houses on the property and
his aunt
um lives in the other house so we can't
sell it until she either passes or moves
out
relationally
you own the other house too you're on
the other house too correct
but she could she could stay there for
about you know who who knows how long
it's up on a hill so they say they think
that you know when she can't make the
stairs anymore she'll move out because
she owns her house she rents out her
house and lives in that house for free
because both houses were in a trust to
my brother and or my husband and
brother-in-law
so so that would be definitely ideal so
that house one more time
the ant
the only hold she has on this whole
situation is relationally not legally
correct
um no and
in the trust she she is allowed to
reside there until she oh she's got a
life estate
yes oh interesting yeah that does cloud
the title okay
you kind of have to wait yeah no you'll
kind of you do
we do we do but the other house just
sits there so we can move into the other
house that's paid for for free and we
basically skip the steps and
you know just search
um I took a different job within the my
I work we both work for the government
and
[Music]
um I took a different position so that
it's we're mandated six days a week and
so now I'll be five days a week
um did did I hear you say at the
beginning of the call that you had a
HELOC and you rolled some other debt
into it
that is correct yes here's um here's
yeah here's my and I know there's not a
a way around it with the property
situation but my issue here is you keep
trying to find ways out of your debt
that does not involve actually paying
your debt
um and I don't really want that behavior
to continue does that make sense and you
have this you you had this convenient
option you know oh we could just move
over here and you know I've definitely
talked about that and you know in this
way yeah I'm not I'm not talking you out
of you know if you want to move and
there's a house there and it's free and
what but something's got to change
behaviorally or else you're just gonna
keep doing this
okay you know what's your household
income
um
over no no no nowadays what
okay and how much debt do you have
um just the the HELOC is now 400 and
that's everything so 186 was the
actually because you take out a giant a
jumbo loan in Hawaii when we bought our
house
um so 186 was the the actual from still
the house 78 is student loans my
daughters and mine 50 000 with solar and
then home improvements and like 10 was
Consumer Debt but all of that's now 400.
yes correct why don't you live on beans
and rice making 240 and pay off 400 and
just stay you don't like your house
[Music]
um I think you're moving to a trashy
house it's a quick fix Dave just looking
for a quick fix I think you guys need to
get on some beans and rice you make a
quarter million dollars a year and
you're broke you spend like you're in
Congress
so yeah you really need to get your
budget dialed down and get this debt
paid off that's what I would do take you
about three years of living on nothing
to do it that's what I would do and keep
your house this is the Ramsey Show
hey what's up guys it's Jade if you love
the show and want a deeper dive on your
money Journey we have a Weekly
Newsletter that gives you trending and
helpful articles and tips on following
the Ramsay way just go to
ramseysolutions.com today to sign up for
our newsletter again that's
ramsesolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsay
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studios it's the
Ramsay show where we help people
build wealth do work that they love and
create actual amazing relationships open
phones this hour Jade Washington Ramsay
personality is my co-host open phones at
Triple A
825-5225 Lynn in Greensboro North
Carolina starts to sell hi Lynn how are
you
better than I deserve what's up
of course and I went with a lump sum
settle out because he was going to
refuse alimony and the divorce was going
to be far off because still covered
behind
um so I chose to take a lump sum to take
care of my children right now we have
joint custody until my son graduate my
oldest and he'll graduate this coming
school year and then I'll have full
custody of my youngest
um with this lump sum
even though the court cases says that he
has to pay 50 because we have joint
custody of all activities school
supplies all of that he just chose not
to so of this song My question is is how
much of it should I set aside to take
care of the part he's the post to take
care of so I
and not
behind yeah
this you said this school year
yeah this school year like he'll
graduate next May
this I mean in one one year from now and
then after that his uncle any
obligations he would have would end
for that child
he'll have one more child are we
supposed to pay 50 of the other one too
that's right for both
I have the option to refuse right I know
I know but to go back to court it's it's
thousands of dollars and then it'll be
after he's gone anyways and it's it's
one year and no it's not one year how
old is that how old's the youngest
uh 14. yeah you got time you need you
you need to get that money
oh I know I know I mean he's I did get a
lump sum so yeah but you said he's he
should be paying 50 of the other kids
charges as well how much is the lump sum
lump sum is 150.
are you earning an income
and what is it
um I earned 36 000.
if I were you I would hold him
accountable for that 50 that he's
supposed to pay because you could use
all the money that you can get
you know what I'm saying
right right okay you didn't get a
million five
you got 150. you got 150. I know it's
not a lot but and I I was going to pay a
huge chunk because I would like to get
the house paid off before
um my youngest graduates so my my plan
was to
put a chunk of it towards that but I
wanted to make sure I had enough money
how are you how are you and the two kids
gonna eat on 30k in Greensboro North
Carolina you doing that okay
yes yes
um okay so I bought a house and my
mother passed away so I got a settlement
from there and that paid for most of my
house or portion of my house 40 of it so
I was going to put try and get it paid
down the settlement is monthly
no the settlement was a lump sum oh so
that put a big chunk down on the house
okay one more time so you currently have
a house payment of how much
my health team is a thousand dollars and
you make thirty thousand and so your
take-home pay is two thousand so your
house payment is fifty percent of your
take-home pay and you have two kids how
are you planning to eat
that budget does not work
right
um
right so I also
get self-support not a lot it's like 400
a month so that's like our food money
and like even with my budget
um so we want to get you to the point
where you're not scraping by like this
33 of my paycheck yeah oh yeah right so
my other thought was this too like we
have rotation uh like I have them three
days a week he has them three days it's
getting a part-time job that when I
don't have the kids that I work those
three days I love that like a rotation I
love that because again it's only 150
000 this is not your big windfall of
life I mean it's great that you have
this money but the bigger thing is your
monthly income you know I love the idea
of being able to put this chunk of money
towards wherever you're at in the baby
steps but at the end of the day you also
want to make sure your monthly income is
all right as well right is the home the
only debt you have
yes okay great what do you owe on it
i o
so you could pay it off today
it wouldn't leave me with any kind of
emergency I got that you'd leave your
seven thousand leave you seven thousand
dollars I did the math yeah okay so
um
yeah and then that shows us right there
the fact that that just made you your
stomach jump up in your throat tells us
you can't make it on what you make right
now
and you can't make it on what you make
right now
that's what you're telling me it makes
me nervous yeah yeah it's not a whole
lot you should
um yes yeah I think you're gonna burn
through this 150 is what I'm trying to
keep you from doing
supplementing your life yeah because
your income's not high enough to feed
your kids and you
with a thousand dollar house payment
that's what's scaring me here and
throwing a little bit at the house
doesn't solve it because the house
payment's still sitting there looking at
you
so I'd love to be able to work the baby
steps too but I think we've got to get
your how in order for you to work the
baby steps your your household monthly
income has to be enough to support you
and the two kids
and um and that may include him paying
the 50 that he needs to be paying
legally
and so yeah
I think uh he needs to be on notice that
your attorney is going to regularly be
dragging his butt into court if he's not
regularly paying what he's supposed to
pay that's called fatherhood hasn't got
anything to do with him being pissed at
you that's fatherhood so that's him
being that's him doing what that's why
the law is there it's not there to give
you a retribution right it's there for
the kids
and so
um oh my gosh so here's what you need
Lynn what we would like for you to do
for your sake is to get your monthly
income be larger than your monthly needs
then we can talk about what to do with
the 150 and then we can worry about
whether you need to fund the other 50 of
expenses that he's not willing to do
without and you're tired of fighting
with this goober and the key is not
piddling away this 150. I'd love for you
to put this somewhere under lock and key
for a minute and get yourself a you know
whatever you said a full-time job or a
part-time job on the other days whatever
you've got to do to get your income Yeah
a different full-time job whatever
you've got to do to get your income up
because if you are not careful this will
nickel and dime its way to nothing yeah
so basically federally the federal
poverty level a single lady with two
kids with a thirty thousand dollar
household income is very close to what
we call poverty
and a thousand dollar house payment
ensures that you're there
so that's what we're worried about for
you hang on I'm going to send you a copy
of Total Money Makeover and help you
work through this I'm scared for you
you've got to get your income balanced
with your expenses before you start
making these other decisions this is the
Ramsay show
[Music]
oh
well you've all played the telephone
game the first person Whispers a message
to the second person who Whispers it to
the third and so on around the table
until the original message has
completely changed multiply that
confusion by a hundred if you run a
business with different software systems
that don't talk to each other that's why
there's netsuite by Oracle in the early
days of Ramsay we were using different
systems for all of our business units we
needed one single source for accurate
data netsuite was the software we used
to optimize and take us to the next
level netsuite gave us the visibility
into all of our numbers so that we could
communicate across departments and plan
ahead better and as we grew it scaled
with us next week worked for Ramsey and
it will make a difference for your
business too join the more than 34 000
customers who trust netsuite to help
make them smarter and make better
decisions and level up their operations
to learn more get a free product tour at
netsuite.com Ramsay that's netsuite.com
Ramsay
foreign
[Music]
personality is my co-host today I'm your
host Dave Ramsey thank you for being
with us open phones at triple eight
eight two five five two two five Doug is
in Anaheim California hi Doug welcome to
the Ramsay show
hi thank you for taking my call sure how
can we help
um I'd like to give you a little
background and then my specific question
is about my two daughters and and
inherit and them inheriting uh my wife
and I's estate okay
um I'm a trustee or successor trustee
for a young lady who's 37 years old and
at age 40 she's gonna she's gonna uh get
the uh her inheritance which is going to
be well right now it's 2.4 million
dollars
and my concern was would is she prepared
to be a millionaire at 40 not you know
when she inherits this you know this is
a you know from from her father and it
means it meant a lot to him and how I
could how I could go about assuring that
she could honor that Legacy so I started
listening to your show about six months
ago and I kept thinking well there's got
to be something here so I called your
Solutions place and uh office and talked
to a gentleman named Irwin I believe
he's a financial specialist and he came
up with a plan that I thought I really
liked and that would be she's going to
be uh get on the Financial Peace
University and in addition to that I'm
going to have a financial coach with her
for a period of time to kind of walk her
through this
so she can establish how to control
money and not not look at you know every
every little thing is oh I can afford
this type of deal so that was the
approach I'm going to take with her
um I I think you would agree with that
yes excellent advice okay now when it
comes to my daughters
um they're they're they're they're very
different people and I don't stick my
nose in their finances
um
one of them seems to be a pretty good
saver and the other one I don't know
um the wild card is they both have
husbands
um and I'm not sure you know you know
how old are your daughter stuck oh one
of them is 38 and the other one is 36.
and um and what did you do for a living
or do you do for a living well I did I I
retired um about uh well I retired in
2018.
um I had a small manufacturing business
I made wheels for cars rims you're yeah
but your um your background was
engineering
no my background was in high school
oh okay and then I just kind of figured
it out from there okay I did a couple of
things and
listening to the reason I'm asking is in
listening to you talk you
um you sound like a very process rule
following
uh type of a person
well to a point yeah I I believe you
need a a process yeah I'm talking to
more of an engineer than to an artist
yeah I'm not an artist
well I mean in terms of the way your
brain works that's why I'm asking
because that helps me to answer the
question properly I'm trying to make
sure I didn't miss something okay okay
so with the first girl let's go to her
let's go ahead and go with all of the
advice
but I want to throw in one other
ingredient and that's relational advice
so the money that you're managing was
your friend and this is his daughter did
I get that right
yeah he was my business partner ah okay
all right so I would have a cup of
coffee with her to start the process of
financial peace and coaching and
um talk about
how much you loved her dad
and how responsible you feel
that you want to you're you're scared to
not help her the right way and you
really want to honor him by helping her
the right way because he loved her so
much and you loved him you loved your
business partner your buddy that you did
this whole deal with this big
manufacturing thing y'all made great
money at both of you and you know you
really liked each other and you want to
you consider her like a daughter and to
honor his memory as his friend you are
really super concerned that you do this
right and I'm a little bit scared about
it because I don't want to mess it up
because of my love for him and how much
I know he loved you and so this is the
best I can do this is how I think you
would do it and I if he were here I
think it's what he would tell you to do
and I think you need to kind of put that
love piece in there
with all of the Tactical steps that you
were given and I think that's also a
good way to approach your daughters then
as well and and so the way we told our
kids is this we believe and we're sure
we're right that the that money doesn't
make you well
money doesn't make you good money
doesn't make you bad and money doesn't
make you sick it exposes where you're
sick weak and where you're strong and
good money magnifies you and so if you
have a daughter that is um doing drugs
and you give her money you will kill her
she'll do so much drugs she'll be in a
ditch if you have a daughter who's
overspending and out of control and
because you don't feel like you're
worthy to interfere in her business you
give her two million dollars you're
going to screw up her life
so I've told our kids if you're
misbehaving
in any area of your life including money
you will get nothing because I love you
too much to magnify your stupidity
okay so that's the kind of conversation
I'm going to have is um there's a whole
bunch of money on the table and I'm not
trying to buy your love and I'm not
trying to buy anything I'm trying to
keep from hurting you because I love you
and if you are have weaknesses that are
greater than your strengths the money
will not be a blessing it will be a
curse and I love you too much to curse
you as your dad and so I will not leave
this to you because I don't want to hurt
you
okay I the
as far as that first conversation I had
that with my business partner's daughter
and it was very similar to what you had
said oh good because I do care for her
she is one of my other daughters and I
care deeply about her I've known her for
25 years
how'd she receive it
very very well she's
um she's gonna enroll in one of the
classes that the financial coach that
that we're going to use is going to be
teaching cool because she thought that
the person that came to her was not
preaching at her but instead cared
deeply for her
yeah and that's what we do with your
daughters too the trick is with grown
kids if there's such a thing I don't
know what grown kids is kind of an
oxymoron but with your children who are
grown
um your offspring that are grown is to
not use your dad voice anymore
yeah yeah it's very hard too I have to
practice it regularly I I struggle with
it because I'm freaking Dave Ramsey you
ought to listen to me I mean come on you
know but no it doesn't work that way it
doesn't work that way I have to the only
option I have with anything with all of
my children are grown in in their 30s is
to is persuasion
and that persuasion starts in love
okay well I thought I would have a
similar conversation with my daughters
and offer them the same opportunity
right offering my my uh partner's
daughter yep and their response to that
dictates how how involved they're going
to be in The Inheritance mm-hmm
exactly and how and how I'm involved I
will be in their financial life
true that true that yeah you're not
trying to be a control freak you're
trying to keep from harming them that's
right and the the one twist that I had
done a little differently was my I'm not
filthy rich but my estate's worth about
14 million dollars that's pretty rich
and my wife and I just screw up
somebody's life well yeah we intend to
give away about 35 40 of that to all
call it worthy causes and then the
balance will decide with our kids if
everything went perfect we would leave
them a lump sum yeah my my the thing I
was thinking about though if it didn't
go so well I might leave
them a monthly stipend
from the trust and then when they pass
away that will go ahead and go to worthy
causes as well you can do that there's
nothing wrong I mean the trick is don't
leave them enough to ruin their life
if they are messed up because money
doesn't make you well
it exposes where you're strong and it
exposes where you're weak and just like
it's done for you it's exposed that
you're a good man the fact that you got
14 million and you're having these
loving kind wise conversations it's
exposed that in you
and uh you know it does that and you
can't keep it from doing that this is
the Ramsay show
[Music]
hey guys being free to make your own
medical decisions is a big deal these
days Christian Healthcare Ministries
gives members the freedom to choose the
doctors and providers they want without
the frustration of worrying about
networks and with no waiting period to
join it's a membership-based non-profit
Ministry where hundreds of thousands of
Christians share funds to pay for and
pray for each other's medical bills for
over 40 years chm has helped families
living across all 50 states so cfchm
could be right for your family check out
more today at
chministries.org budget
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
personality is my co-host open phones at
triple eight eight two five five two two
five Audrey's with us in Plymouth New
Hampshire hi Audrey how are you
I'm doing great it's such an honor to
speak with you both you too
so my question is are we in a place to
be intentional or intense and this is
kind of coming to a deeper question of
if we should go through the hassle of
selling our truck
let's hear more
all right so I've had a ton of Life
Changes in the past four years which is
when I met my now husband we got married
um two years ago we moved to uh from
Delaware to New Hampshire uh in that
process we've been on one income between
changing jobs for the past year okay
um and we have a daughter who there's
been some complications with
establishing custody from uh with
okay our father okay
how much how much is the truck worth
it is worse about
um
we do
what do you owe on it
oh here's the kicker
um it's ten thousand that we owe to my
in-laws it was my father-in-law's truck
and um so it's worth 28 you owe 10.
what's your other car worth
and what's it worth
worth
22 okay and so what's your household
income
now
yeah so currently our income is has been
about 50k and is it getting ready to
change
yeah it's going to go to like uh 1 15.
when does that happen
um I'm a school teacher so in August
okay so your income is 115 and you owe
60 000 on vehicles okay so a general
rule of thumb that's good to think about
is cars go down in value very rapidly as
a matter of fact they're the largest
thing we buy that goes down in value all
of us okay and so we lose more money on
cars than just about anything else we do
and so you if you want to become wealthy
you need to try to avoid losing money as
much as possible so we tell folks not to
have vehicles things with motors uh
Wheels uh anything that falls under the
vehicle heading added up altogether
because they all go down in value to be
more than half your annual income yours
is right at half your annual income
it's on the bubble
so if you want to accelerate the process
of getting out of debt and Building
Wealth yeah you would move down in car
but is it necessary for you to survive
no you probably can sweat your way
through it if you love the vehicle
is there any way the second car that's
paid off is there any way you could sell
it for it's you said it's worth 22k
could you give 10 to the your parents
for car one and then buy another vehicle
for ten thousand dollars
yeah and buy a car with a difference
because they only owe 10 on it
that's true 18 000. the argument that I
get from my husband is that um my car
that's paid off eBay is brand new and
you know so that now it's super reliable
and I don't give a crap
you bought it new you know what it is
now used is this the only debt or is
there more debt besides this
there's more debt so our student loans
are about to kick in and I never had
student loan payments before so that's
where I'm feeling the pressure how much
is your student loan
37 between the two of us okay and then
that's it is there anything else
not counting down like a thousand on a
credit card but yeah okay uh
again you can fight your way through
ten thousand and thirty seven thousand
is forty seven thousand dollars worth of
debt making 115.
and keep the car okay you can fight your
way through that if you want to
accelerate that by ten thousand dollars
you could sell the car and buy an
eighteen thousand dollar or less car for
cash and then only have the student
loans to attack
um but the big thing here is you two
have got to get on the same page about
what's important and where you want to
be and how fast you want to get there I
think you could pay off thirty seven
thousand dollars worth of debt if you
live on beans and rice and don't go on
vacation and quit eating out and tighten
up your lifestyle because you want to
keep this car and you want to clear the
student loan debt you could probably pay
that off in two years
and be a hundred percent debt free and
keep the car yep but you're going to
have to sacrifice for a little longer
because you kept the car and then you
need to recognize as part of that is
that we're right on the bubble that
regardless of when we bought the car
whether the car was new whether it was
used whether I lived in New Hampshire
whether I lived in Delaware it doesn't
keep it doesn't flipping matter what
matters is you got a lot of money tied
up going and think going backward going
down in value that's what matters and
you got to stop that for going forward
if you want to win with money
in other words the pattern the the
conversation pattern you're using with
your husband leads you to call me back
three years from now and say we just
bought a sixty thousand dollar truck
right my husband wanted a new one
right and we ain't doing that
that's stupid is he fully on board with
this no he's not
right we're not we're not on the same
page like we plan to have a conversation
when he gets home from work and and
really tighten up our budget make a
decision and it seems like this car is
kind of a pivotal point on which attack
we take with our budget yeah the card
the one that you owe ten thousand did
you say that that's to his parents
yes is that why you want to get rid of
the money
yes that's absolutely right yeah and
that's why you're willing to sell a car
to do it and he's not necessarily ready
to do that right okay yeah so that that
adds to the equation as well so because
the borrower is slave to the lender and
when you have Thanksgiving dinner it
tastes different when you eat with your
master especially when it's the in-laws
yeah that's all I'm saying
turkey tastes like turkey
yeah
I think there's a lot of stuff you got
to talk about here a we need to get on
the same page that's Paramount B we need
to agree that we're not going to
continue to invest in things that go
down in value going forward regardless
of which decision we make with this car
okay C it makes me uncomfortable that we
owe your parents and it weirds me out
and it's awkward as crud
d right okay D we can fight through this
together but if we do that there's going
to be required of both of us a deep
sacrifice in lifestyle because we have
forty seven thousand dollars in Consumer
Debt standing between us and the ability
to build wealth so there's really four
things going on here that you all need
to address the first of which and most
important is that you two are together
and unified at the end of the
conversation because no one wins with
money dragging the other spouse along
right
and so I don't care if you keep the
truck financially I don't care if you
keep it relationally with your in-laws
you'll get through it it's only going to
be two years Max and it'll probably be
one of the first things you pay off
anyway so it's okay it was I think it
was a truck one at a truck yeah okay and
but but I for for your sake five years
from today I really care that you're on
the same page and you're not you're
talking circles around each other about
a bunch of symptoms rather than the
problems through that although I will
say Dave I would wait I weigh more into
that that in-law situation I'd be trying
to get at it I hightail it out of that
lickety-split I would I get if I were
you if I were in your shoes if I could
get unified I would sell it me too but
if I if I have to keep it and work
through to get agreement on everything
else that's true I'll deal with it yeah
but uh but I I there's a lot of reasons
to get rid of this car a lot of reasons
and um you know the in-law pressures the
awkwardness of that the car is right on
the bubble it's a lot of vehicle you
guys don't have that kind of income
you're not making 300 Grand you're
making 115. yeah and so you know that
that's there's a lot of reason to do
this but you know that's the list of
priorities first get on the same page
second degree we're not going to invest
period that's that's a non-negotiable in
things that go down in value cars yep
that are more than half our annual
income going forward we're not
regardless of the rationalization
because people can rationalize their
butts off on a car more than anything
else
see he needs to acknowledge that this is
awkward to owe for you to owe his
parents money he needs to acknowledge
that he needs to feel that from you in
your marriage that's really good and
then D are we willing to sacrifice to
keep it and get the student loan and
this paid off that's right and then make
the decision and be all in both of you
up break the Huddle go this is the
Ramsey Show
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
foreign
personality is my co-host today
Jade it Bears repeating
um because it was something that having
I mean I'm just babbling all right so I
grew up
in this financial world in the academic
side and in the professional financial
side
and the problem with us Financial groups
nerds
is that we thought I thought and most of
them think that you solve your money
problems
with math
yeah math is part of it we always say
around here personal finance is 80
Behavior it's 20 head knowledge the
mathematics of becoming a
multi-millionaire you learn by the sixth
grade right there is no calculus
involved no trigonometry involved the
Pythagorean theorem is not involved
thank God okay there's no geometry
involved there is uh it is it is
multiplication addition division that's
it you know some subtraction a little
basically but yeah I mean that's the
mathematics of wealth building so it
really isn't math
if we were doing math he wouldn't ever
go take out a credit card and run up 18
or 20 percent debt because that's just
freaking mathematical Insanity that's
right no no sane human would do that and
say I did that for mathematical reasons
that's complete BS so this is not a math
problem it's a behavior problem
and that was really hard for me in the
early days of doing what I do today 30
years ago because I'm always trying I'm
a math guy I'm always trying to fix it
with the math right but it's not a math
problem and the part that goes with that
is even harder
is you're not by yourself
you got all these other dadgum humans
in the equation that's called
relationships that you actually have to
talk into doing crap yeah that's smart
that's your kids your grown kids your
grandkids and most of all your spouse
as we studied over ten thousand
millionaires over 85 percent of them
said their spouse was a contributing
factor the unity in their relationship
was a contributing factor in their
ability to build wealth meaning that
over 85 percent of millionaires work
together with their spouse are unified
in their approach to life and money
that's right
so if you think you're going to drag
some princess into wealth
or princess you think you're going to
drag some guy who won't work or doesn't
want to participate I'll I'll work hard
I'm gonna get me a truck no you're just
a redneck
that's all you are I know you I am you I
get it I got a truck in the parking lot
with loud dadgum mufflers I get I know
who you are okay I get who you are but
that but you don't work hard enough to
be stupid I work hard I deserve you
don't deserve spit shut up
you know you got to learn to work
together with your spouse and we hear
this over and over and over again and I
don't know if we spend enough time on
this show talking about it's freaking
vital but you're on the same page yep
it's vital accountability that's part
part of the reason one of the one of the
benefits of marriage is accountability
and holding each other but accountable
and make each other better and if you're
not willing to uh get on the same page
with one of your most important parts of
your marriage which is your finances
this is an opportunity for you to
exercise that muscle but a lot of people
won't do it because it takes work it'll
change your marriage in a positive way
when you learn how to handle money
because where you spend your money Jesus
said your Treasures where your heart is
where you spend your money says what's
important to you that's right Thank God
It's Friday I'm gonna hit the bars we
know what's important to you you know
I'm going to save for the future we know
it's important to you I'm gonna say for
my kids and we know it's important I'm
going to save so much I'm gonna change
my family tree my kids and my great can
grandkids now we know what's important
to you
I want a car now we know what's
important to you I want some shoes
what's those shoes Rachel's got with the
red bottom oh Christian Louboutin oh
those are Jimmy Jimmy shoe yeah those
dad gum shoes are expensive you better
you better be freaking Rachel Cruz if
you're gonna she can wear them she can
get those she can get as many as she
wants if you're gonna buy those shoes by
God you need to have some coin I know
that's right all right and that's just
you know that's a deal but if you are a
woman and you come home with those shoes
and you're making 60 000 a month or a
year and your kids college funded and
funded
hello I must threw the pin I must threw
the pin don't throw the pin oh I won't
throw it at you Jade throws the pen it's
over that is a glaring indicator that
you become what's known as an
irresponsible
human being
clean that up I did I've had to clean it
up a couple of times Dave
that was awesome I can't say everything
I want to say but you know you know what
I'm saying you know what irresponsible
human being yeah
[Music]
seriously if you can't and I I got to
tell you I've been married 41 years
Sharon I just got back from an
anniversary trip we were living like no
one else we've been gone for three weeks
all right and
um
you know what we did on that trip
anything we wanted you know why because
most of our Lives we didn't do
everything we wanted if you live like no
one else later you can live and give
like no one else you've had to pay a
freaking price to win no one wins
accidentally and part of the price is
sometimes my wife is right
I don't like that
but it's also true who can find a
virtuous wife for her worth is far above
rubies the heart of her husband safely
trusts her get this part he will have no
lack of gain
when I'm in when I'm when my wife who's
a full-time mom for 40 38 years
uh has an opinion about something maybe
Dave Ramsey needs to listen to that
because maybe if I don't it's going to
cost me in excess of 10 grand every time
I go against one of her feelings that
doesn't mean she's always right but it
means I need to respect that and we've
got to be if we're not in agreement on
major purchases or major giving and our
giving sometimes is more difficult these
days to decide on than purchases yeah
because if we're going to give a chunk
to something and really help some
movement or thumb some thing over here
and we're not in agreement we don't both
have a good feeling about the group that
we're dealing with that Ministry that
we're dealing with then we don't go
forward and that's good you know that's
so good Dave because when you're not on
the same page or when the guy just
thinks I'm going to do what I want or
the the woman thinks I'm going to do
what I want there's a lack of respect
there at the core and that's why some
sometimes when we get calls and it's
like you know I'm trying to do this
thing but you know my spouse is doing
another thing I'm always like this is
not a money problem not the core this is
you he doesn't respect you or you don't
respect him and that is a bigger problem
because at the end of the day you need
to be able to have these conversations
and feel like
that person's listening to you feel like
they're respecting what you're saying
feel like they care enough about what
you're saying to enact some sort of
change whether it's something that
you're compromising on or them fully
coming over to your side or vice versa
but when that's not there y'all got
y'all got troubles and it's not money
trouble that's right and it's gonna it's
gonna come up again and again and again
and you're going to struggle with your
money that's right because opposites do
attract that nerd will attract that free
spirit that person who loves to save
will attract that person who loves to
spend I'm a spender Sharon's a natural
saver I'm a nerd I like to do the
budgets the projects she couldn't care
less about the details yeah this trip we
were on I've got to have everything
ironed out I got to know exactly where
we're going to win I don't making it up
as you go is not relaxing for Dave
you got the itinerary completely she's
per yeah but she she knew the itinerary
but she would just be asking me what are
we doing next because she doesn't want
to do that so Opposites Attract Larry
Burkett used to say it's a good thing
because if two people just alike get
married one of you is unnecessary so you
need each other you need the strengths
of the other one and you need to be
unified off of those strengths but if
you're making all your decisions with
half your brain because one of you is
not voting or one of his vote doesn't
count in the relationship then you are
not going to win relationally and you're
not going to win with your money it is
there's not an exception this is a
universal rule I'm independent good
don't get married
you're gonna be a useless spouse that is
so true I'm independent or kiss my no
way yeah no way please don't screw up
somebody else's life with your
Independence when you get married you're
by God dependent for richer for poorer
in sickness and in health Choose Wisely
who's making the chicken soup when you
got the flu Miss Independent Mr
independent
your butt be up in the bed looking for
some food that's what's happening come
on that's not independent that's
dependent this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
Dave here you can find all of our shows
with the Ramsay Network app on your
smartphone it's the only place to listen
to the entire back catalog of episodes
download the Ramsay Network app in your
favorite app store today
thank you
[Music]
foreign
from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studios it's the
Ramsay show where we help people build
wealth to work that they love and create
actual amazing relationships Jade wash
all Ramsay personality is my co-host
today open phones at triple eight eight
two five five two two five Gabriel is
with us in Fort Wayne Indiana hi Gabriel
how are you
doing well how about yourself better
than I deserve how can we help
so uh glad to speak with both of you
this today Dave and Jade I'm going to
Dive Right In my fiance and I are
getting married in October yay thank you
and we're both entering the senior years
of our debt-free degrees
but between scholarship refunds and our
part-time jobs we don't make much how
can we best be financially prepared for
all the changes that are coming with
marriage welcoming children graduation
moving home all of those things well
what are you going to be making when you
do get your degrees and get into your
career field what are you expecting
uh I'm studying supply chain so I'm
expecting uh north of 55 a year and then
my fiance uh is studying athletic
training so we're not sure but uh
probably around 40. now when do you
graduate
in May of 24.
okay so your your first several months
of marriage you're not going to have
much of an income
correct where are you planning on living
in a house that we're renting near uh
her school okay so we already know what
that budget is and it's affordable
correct okay all right are you guys
earning anything now yeah a little bit
you said you had some part-time stuff
going right
that's right yep I'm a forklift driver
uh for about 20 hours a week or so cool
so what are you what are you bringing in
um between scholarships and before Cliff
driving it comes out to about uh 45
000 a year uh after taxes
okay what about your fiance
uh right around five thousand a year not
much so you guys are just going to
scrape through till May and get your big
jobs in a year from now yeah and so are
almost a year from now so
um and you have no debt at all right
good for you well done okay and so you
said your question was
get married uh set up life have kids all
that kind of stuff right so a lot of
this stuff is going to happen after May
right
not the marriage but a bunch of the
other things
um we're we're yeah that's that's kind
of what what we're talking about is uh
how how do we
um with with the potential to have
children after we're married we'd like
to be able to be excited whenever that
that moment comes uh whether that would
involve having both big boy and big girl
jobs
what's that yeah that's not going to
happen on the end you're not going to be
excited on the income you have now right
right that's right okay so you'll be
excited after May so you know that's
what I'm saying so you get married in
October you live like a couple of
college students as roommates except
your married roommates uh until May and
then we start all the other life
planning stuff after May when the
incomes come is that fair
I I think so yeah yeah I think anything
else will scare the crap out of me right
and oh by the way you should be making
closer to 100 not 55 in supply chain
really yeah coming out of the gate
making 80 80 minimum yeah
I'm here for that absolutely now that
would make it a lot easier to be excited
right yeah yeah about about a lot of
stuff but yeah so uh I mean so what I
would do is what you're asking is kind
of how to set up so I would set up the
household in the budget like a couple of
college students living on uh you know
day old bread in last week's mayonnaise
right and that kind of stuff until you
get to May because that's what you've
been doing it's how you've made it this
far right
right yeah you don't need to change that
plan until your income changes you're
living in the house that you're going to
be who's living in the house that you're
going to be renting because somebody's
already living there right right so I'm
living in it currently and she's uh
being a summer ra the good news is we
are married we'll both be living there
yeah the good news is you've already
been living there on the income you have
you've already been holding up your
lifestyle she's going to come into that
is she has no debt right
correct okay so and she's bringing you
know five thousand dollars whatever to
the table so it sounds like you like
Dave said you've got enough to just keep
camping the way you have been then you
know A1 after you graduate is getting
you know the jobs that you say that
you're gonna get and then after that you
know do you guys have any money saved
it'll be around 10 000 after the the
weddings all suddened up for good that's
that's more than I thought you would
have yeah okay that's good yeah I think
you're doing great yeah me too yeah just
get you know but just don't don't line
up something to do until the money's
there to do it so I would I would move
out of that in May after you get your
good jobs and rent something else a
little nicer and now let's set up house
let's get some dishes all that kind of
stuff from May forward for one year
during that one year I'd save like crazy
to start talking about buying a house
and have your down have a down payment
plus an emergency fund and debt free
learning to live together learning live
on a budget but wait a year after
marriage to buy a house because it takes
a little while to know which house to
buy you got to get to know each other
and it's different
uh being married than it is not being
married and so that's going to change
the decision-making process and the
house you buy the joke we always use is
it takes a year of marriage to know how
close to your mother-in-law to buy right
but the uh but but what it must do is
you need to get to know each other and
um it's okay to go a little bit slow on
the home purchase thing but the rest of
it if you're going to move up in car or
whatever pay cash for it and every time
you spend a dime on something more than
your emergency fund after May you're
going to be spending some of your down
payment money so you're going to delay
the purchase on the home but that's okay
if it takes you a little while it's okay
you're just getting out of college you
got time you've got all kinds of time
and you guys are going to be doing
really well you're going to be making
north of 100 Grand between the two of
you
and um you know this time next year one
year from today life's gonna look really
different in in a lot of good ways a lot
of fun ways and uh so congratulations
very wise in how you've approached it
they've done a lot of things right
that's very good you need to go through
Financial Peace University as our guest
we're going to give that to you as an
engagement present and you guys can go
through and start talking about a lot of
these things now we'll teach you
everything about that you should have
been taught about money before we let
you out in the world and uh we'll show
you exactly how to do that I'm going to
pay for it it'll be our gift to you so
thanks thanks again for joining us and
congratulations hang on
um Austin will pick up and get you
signed up for Financial Peace University
good man don't you wish everybody I wish
I had started with that I know I know I
calling and wanting wanting to be ahead
and I'm you're already
dead you're already so far ahead uh yeah
good things for them
the up and up yep yep yep yep wow very
cool stuff hey thanks for joining us
America you got questions about your
life and your money that's what we're
here for open phones at triple eight
eight two five five two two five this is
the Ramsay show
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
hey Dr John deloney here I'm a huge fan
of both meditation and prayer and good
mental health includes slowing down
gaining control of your thoughts and
plugging into something bigger than you
and Halo makes it easy to start a daily
practice of meditation prayer and
finding peace Hollow is the number one
Bible app in the world and you can
tailor content towards your faith
tradition from scripture readings and
prayers to meditation and journaling
hallow makes it easy to practice prayer
meditate and build a deeper more
meaningful spiritual life and ReDiscover
true peace go to hollow.com Ramsay today
to get three months of hallow for free
that's hallow.com Ramsay
[Music]
foreign
personality is my co-host today open
phones at triple eight eight two five
five two two five well Jade if you go on
vacation for three weeks stuff happens
while you're gone yeah a lot how you
were gone so first thing that happened
Supreme Court rules and says um
President Joe Biden does not have the
power to forgive student loans
that's the second thing that happens is
Joe Biden came out with an announcement
that they were forgiving a bunch of
student loans which was actually a
complete falsehood because the student
loan process already involved
forgiveness for people that did the uh
the PLC Public Service uh process and it
was 10 years and now it's going to be 25
years and you just went on a rant last
week about that which has now got over
300 000 views that's right rent and so
it's not the same forgiveness guys it's
not it's not it's not student loan
forgiveness at all no it was by the way
by the way of the people that signed up
for that when it was a 10-year program
that are now coming up on 10 years
almost no one has gotten less than five
percent of people who've actually gotten
the Forgiveness so one more time the
government lied to you whether they're
Republicans or whether they're Democrats
it doesn't matter you can tell they're
lying about the student loan issue if
their mouth is moving that's right and
then this comes out today and this is
this one is not as maddening from the
daily wire as it is sad well this is sad
because this is about you the people a
third of student loan debt holders spent
the extra money that they thought would
be wiped clean so we know um I'll just
read this
um the poll by intelligent.com surveyed
977 people who would have qualified for
at least ten thousand dollars of relief
under Biden's plan now we know that was
struck down but you know we've all
talked about this so many people thought
oh I'm gonna get this forgiveness Dave
or people whose loans were paid off they
got that refund back of ten thousand
dollars and they thought and they didn't
they didn't get it they spent the money
and I learned that again they're in debt
again they were out of debt let's put
them back in debt that's right and uh
this this this came through and I
thought you know this is it because a
while back I was on here ranting saying
you guys were spending this money on
hamburgers and it looks like I'm a
little bit right it says of those one in
three people said they spent the extra
money because they were assuming
forgiveness and many of them spent the
money on things like vacations real
retail items
alcohol drugs and gambling
sounds responsible to me I would have
been happier with the hamburger
alcohol drugs and gambling okay we need
Dr John deloney in here but
this is unbelievable that's very
important I mean over half of borrowers
now say they don't feel prepared once
student loan repayment starts back up in
October with 35 saying they're very
unprepared well I mean
uh we got a little time let's get
prepared let's get prepared let's get
prepared guys apparently
gambling drugs alcohol retail and
vacations are not getting prepared no
that who knew that's
you
[Laughter]
I was not going to cause wealth
buildings yeah you're gonna have to cut
back on the Alcohol budget in the
gambling budget
and the Lululemon budget and the Sandals
vacation all-inclusive budget the
Supreme Court decision is a cold shower
for those who had their hopes pinned on
a ten thousand dollar relief James Allen
who founded personal finance website
Bullpen said uh it's like waiting for a
tax refund only to find out the IRS made
a mistake is it
is it though
no it's not because you never should
have been waiting on it we told you not
to wait on it we told you we told you to
use the time and get them get the stupid
but we're here now we're here now so now
you can get prepared since you feel
unprepared and the way you get prepared
is
um you start living on less than you
make and you quit waiting on anyone with
a zip code anywhere near Washington DC
to fix your life that's right and on a
prac even a more practical tip you guys
really need to don't bury your head in
the sand on this you need to go online
look at your service provider because
the fact is Dave a lot of the people a
lot of the servicers that were servicing
the loans pre-covered are no longer
they've been sold off to somebody else
so if you yeah if you've been getting
those emails and you've been ignoring
those Now's the Time to stop ignoring
the emails and really get organized find
out where your loan is or your loans are
find out how much what the full balance
is find out do not bury your head in the
sand find out what the payment's gonna
be all right you need to know this
information and then you need to start
looking at here's Dave this is the drum
I want to be
do not I repeat do not because some of
you that were in income driven repayment
plans prior to they're just
automatically enrolling you and yet
another income driven repayment plan
right and you can go on there yourself
and estimate your income and say this is
what I make this is what I want my
payment to be if you should get an
income repayment plan you're going to be
in debt the rest the rest of your life
and that's what that mathematical you
that's the case that's not a
philosophical statement it's not a
political that's just a math thing that
what you guys heard us rant about last
week about Biden forgiveness that was
people
those income driven repayment plans they
had been paying 25 and 30 years
is that what you really no is that work
s
Wrong listen this is taking the student
loan business and applying the rules of
the DMV to it that's right this is
stupid government socialist Behavior
yeah that's who's working there and it's
just it's ridiculous and it's a disaster
if you lean on this for your future so
your future let me hit you you want to
get your student loans get rid of your
student loans here's how you do it
what we call Big math big math Works
somewhere around the fourth grade
so you owe ten thousand dollars okay
that's 833 dollars a month
or if you wanna do it in one year okay
or it's sixteen hundred and sixty six
dollars a month if you wanna do it in
six months okay it's ten it's a thousand
dollars a month if you wanna do it in 10
months it's five thousand dollars a
month if you wanna do it in two months
so take your take your student loan and
divide it by how long you want to be a
Slave
how many months and that tells you what
you've got to go make and get up off
your freaking couch
go leave the cave kill something and
drag it home and get this dead gum thing
out of your life this crap owns your
life and they're sitting up there in
Washington playing tiddlywinks with your
dad gum life and you gave them
permission yeah because you leaned on
something that didn't need to be leaned
on that wasn't worthy being leaned on
called politics and you're kidding
yourself if you think
and you're gonna look up 10 years from
now and let me tell you any financial
situation that you have ignored
has a high rate of Resurrection as my
friend
that's right okay you try to bury this
stuff it comes back with a Zombie
Vengeance like six more zombies than you
had when you buried the first one yeah
it's gonna come back and it comes back
with a vengeance so he comes back with
extra fees extra gotchas lawyer fees and
all of a sudden they show up at your
work and garnish you your dad gum wages
so and they have unlimited power to do
this stuff that's right that's right you
do not want to screw around with this
take the dollars that you owe today and
divide it by the number of months you
want to be in pain and then go get your
pain over with that's right get it done
get it behind you rip the Band-Aid off
sell so much stuff the kids think
they're next yeah hello I mean in this
world you can make some money right now
there's a lot of people paying a lot of
money for people to do
look Dave with the internet the way that
it is you could do you can do so much
there's so many ways to make money
please do not let these companies the
government fool you into thinking a
lower payment is better half of those in
the old in the old westerns
the uh you know the Indians were
attacking the the Pioneers the Pioneers
are circling the wagons and then you'd
hear this bugle sound and here comes the
calvary
to save them right so what Jade and I
are trying to tell you is the calvary
ain't coming
you're it
you're it look in the mirror you are
your financial salvation you and God
get a hold of his hands jump up get your
butt in gear and get to work and clean
this up take the amount of student loan
debt that you have the dollar amount and
divide it by the number of months you
want to be in pain and then go find that
much money in your budget or with extra
income and get it out of your life you
don't have to do the interest rate
division you don't have to do I want to
be in yet the rest of my dadgum life I'm
going to be on income repayment that's
dumber than a rock that tells me I don't
know how you got out of the sixth grade
running that kind of math that's dumb
it's just dumb don't be dumb dumb will
make you broke this is the Ramsay show
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
thank you for joining us America Jade
wash all Ramsey personality is my
co-host Sadie's with us in Denver Hi
zadie how are you
I'm great how are you guys better than I
deserve what's up
well thank you so much for taking my
call I'm calling because my husband and
I have been following your baby steps
since we got married three years ago and
we paid off our student debt in 2020.
yay you know what she said about the
student loans hopefully we're not part
of that sucker group but anyway so
thankfully he's getting a masters now
and we are paying cash for that but my
question is actually related to buying a
home so we have about a year and a half
left we're paying cash for that Masters
and we are trying so hard to save up
money to buy a home here in Denver oh
expensive marketing
yes exactly so what I want to talk to
you guys about is we're trying to
maintain some sanity here while saving
up a lot of money for a down payment I'm
hoping to save up about two hundred
thousand dollars for most homes that are
you know modest homes about half a
million dollars yes so we're trying our
best to do that but it's looking like
it's going to take three to five years
which I'm thinking means that we have to
be gazelle intense but I'm kind of
wondering if you guys have any insight
for that because again we're trying to
maintain our set our sanity so his
master's is in what
he's getting a master's Masters in
marriage and family counseling okay and
what's he do for a living now
what he does he works part-time for an
extension of foster systems he helps
kids and families so when he's a
licensed therapist what will be the
change in Euros income did you calculate
that as part of the equation you gave us
yeah I did so part of it is now that I'm
new to the Denver area I can be a travel
nurse here because I'm a nurse and I can
make very good money doing that I last
year I made 200 000 of this travel nurse
this year I'm making less just because
contracts are not as good I'm making
close to like 120 140. yeah
um eventually the travel nurse contracts
will go away all together when we live
here permanently so I'll make about
probably 80 to 100 at that point and
he'll probably make about 75. so
actually the thing is we won't our
income won't change a whole lot because
my income is going to go down so
dramatically that's fair okay good
you've you figured this out you're ahead
of me well done all right so what you're
saying is is you might not put down as
big a down payment on this first house
but you're still going to be making 175
and you're still going to go in and
knock it out as fast as you can
um and so if you don't put down 200 you
put down 100 that's not the end of the
world right
yeah and I actually I have a hundred
thousand dollars saved but um the issue
yeah that kind of the issue we're seeing
is um with just with the way our budget
is and how much his master's degree is
costing we're struggling to save you
know two to five thousand dollars but
that's not a permanent situation that's
just until he completes the Masters
I see so you guys yeah I probably just
need to be more patient but maybe you
guys can tell but I'm I'm sure when she
finished you're wanting to buy now while
he's in the master's program
no I'd like to buy him maybe
12 months to 24 months and will he be
out by that
he will barely okay is he going to go
into private practice or is he going to
join a practice or what's his plan
yeah that's a good question so he'll
have to be an apprentice and he the
great news is he has a great
um kind of clinical site set up as a
student and hopefully they'll hire him
on once he has his degree and um he has
to charge less because he needs
supervised hours for the first two years
he has his license oh so it's not gonna
it's not going to kick in immediately
okay yeah I would not I I would be
careful because I would not buy
something based on a projected future
income correct you know what I'm saying
because that's going to put a lot of
pressure on him that could be
yeah that could be months and years
where the payment feels you know too
tight for you guys so it almost Works
hand in hand if you're saying hey this
could take three to five years to save
what we want and what you want to put
down that could work well with the you
know his career and you guys finally
seeing where you're going to actually be
in three years time so zaidi um here's
the overall thing you have done a better
job analyzing this than we have in the
last five minutes because you've spent a
lot more than five minutes on it and you
are really doing a really good job
thinking about this and actually I think
your numbers are fairly accurate because
I didn't have the two-year and I was
anticipating his income jumping faster I
didn't have the two-year internship
built in I didn't see your travel nurse
stuff coming down you're seeing all that
you've done a good job with your
critical thinking skills on building out
your model okay it's just frustrating
you that you don't like the answer your
model is giving you
that's right yeah okay all right and
that I can't help you with that it's
time and so you know that that's going
to require one of two things one is you
don't put down as much of a down payment
and you buy sooner or two back to your
earlier comment you have some patience
so you can put down more neither plan
that you've told me is in the stupid
column though
you're not going to land in the stupid
column because you're you're you're
putting too much good logical thought to
this you're doing a really good job with
this
yeah and so I just I just
want to oh I'm sorry it's okay I would
just say to you and your husband that
the two of you sitting down talking
about this the way you have been
analyzing it up to this point I would
trust yourself you you I would trust you
to make the decision you're making
really good
process here you know what I'm saying so
I I and and once you can trust yourself
a little bit then you go okay this is
what we're going to do and put down a
little less and we're going to purchase
a little sooner or we're going to have
some patience and then own that decision
and rest in it and quit fretting over it
okay I'm gonna pick your brain about
something really brief I know we have
limited time so kind of the issue he he
thinks that I'm being paranoid about how
much we need to save which is
understandable I think we need to make
our mortgage as low as possible just
given I don't trust anything about the
climate of what's been happening in the
world the past five years
you might be borderline paranoid but
you're at least driven to good decisions
I like it okay Hey listen one of the
benefits of being debt free is I mean
you've been travel nursing and covid for
God's sakes okay one of the benefits of
being debt free is when something like a
stupid and weird like a pandemic or
worse than that a quarantine from a
pandemic occurs
um maybe not worse than that but as bad
as that for other people is um the
quarantine and we don't know you know
all that uncertainty
it melts away when you don't mean dead
and so I love your conclusion but you
don't want to be driven to a Neurosis
over it I mean you want to have some
peace about it that's why I said lay out
your plan leave your plan and and just
rest in your plan because you are the
kind of people they're going to put
together a good plan
okay so that's what I mean by trusting
that and that'll that'll you know if he
senses you relaxing then the word
paranoia can come off of the table
it's not real paranoia but he's just
he's afraid you're over worrying yeah
yeah no he he's he he knows me well and
he has good insight there yeah yeah so
and I think you probably are you're a
planner but you know sometimes those of
us that are planners are also fretters
we fret yep worry
Pace back and forth when's the dadgum
plan gonna happen you know and I don't
know anybody like that I just have to
look at him in the mirror every morning
but right you know so yeah I mean
nothing happens fast enough to suit Dave
but um
yeah I'm the guy that thinks microwaves
are slow so what are you waiting on I
want my burrito sometimes that minute it
takes it's forever
watching watching uh water boil right it
won't boil while you watch yeah so yeah
that's but uh guys do what's you know be
Sadie yeah right you know plan plan lay
it you know look at the variables what
she's doing is what Jim Collins talks
about in business he talks about face
the last 10 percent of Truth and and the
last 10 percent of truth is I'm not
there's no fairy tale involved
Prince Charming the wicked witch they
aren't there this is just a thing it's a
thing it's a math thing and we're just
going to lay it out and we're going to
walk through it and that last 10 percent
of truth then then rest in it once
you've addressed it yeah and because all
you can do I used to work for a guy he
said all you can do is all you can do
and that's enough that's right well that
it's true it's all you can do so it
might as well be enough that's where it
ends good job Sadie good job we're
honored to have you in our listening
audience thank you this is the Ramsey
Show
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
our scripture of the day First
Corinthians 15 57 but thanks be to God
he gives us the victory through our Lord
Jesus Christ Winston Churchill said
difficulties mastered are opportunities
one yeah that's how you build a callus
that's right John's with us John is in
Raleigh North Carolina hey John welcome
to Ramsey Show
yes sir Mr Andrews pleasure to speak
with you you too sir how can we help
so Mr Ramsey I bought a home
um about three months ago and I bought
it about fifty thousand dollars less
than it's worth
um but I bought it at auction and it's
my first home that I've ever purchased
and I've come to realize why it sold so
cheap
whether it has major septic issues and
so I've had some professionals over the
last month come out
and
uh give me some quotes on what it would
cost to get the work done and it's
looking around the 25 000 range
um I've got about ten thousand dollars
in the bank
and I'm kind of pulling my hair out as
to what to do
so it's not functioning at all
uh no sir so so you can't live in the
house you can't live in the house
I have maybe another month I could live
in the house and then it's going to be
everywhere okay
um how many different people in that
world have you had to look at this
it's been three so far
um and on the cheap side
um it's been around the 25 000 Mark okay
yeah
[Applause]
can you do you know what's wrong with it
yes yes we know exactly what's wrong
with it what's wrong with the field the
entire field needs to be replaced it's
an older house by 60 years old and has
all original pipes and everything it's
all cast iron and they basically all
collapsed yeah okay
um yeah well I've done real estate
rehabs for just about my whole adult
life that's why I was asking because
I've made these similar mistakes so I'm
sorry I'm afraid you've gotten an
accurate bid what do you make for a
living
how much money do you want to make about
50 000 a year good Lord
and I'm a huge fan of yours I have no
debt you know I've been a follower for
years I just I started talking to the 25
000 guy and ask him how functional we
can get this
for the first 10 because you don't have
25. so if you can get it functional get
one for your line operating and it
because you don't have the health
department shutting you down you just
got practicality shutting you down
because your backyard's getting ready to
be stinking
yes sir yeah within about a month no
water will be able to leave the house
yeah so you've got to get at least one
fill Line open and you probably do that
for 10 grand there's usually three or
four fill lines I don't know how big
this property is but I'm guessing there
is and then they they generally head
towards a tank you pump the tank I
assume right
yes sir I think okay and so that's not
helping at all because the water's not
getting there because of the collapsed
lines right
[Music]
because the lines aren't the lines
leaving the tank are what's not working
right
yes sir I can get it pumped which costs
about 600 and after it's pumped by about
three weeks or two weeks before it's
filled back up yeah yeah so I'm gonna
I'm Gonna Keep pumping it until I can
get the enough fill lines in that I
don't have to pump it anymore and you
may have to do one fill line at a time
you got ten thousand dollars worth see
if you can't get two in see if the guy
tell the guy what you're up against say
I don't have any money and I can't
borrow money and I don't make I don't
make 500 000 and so you know help me man
and see how help me figure out how we
can do this in phases rather than and at
least get it semi-operational that's
what I would do if I woke up in your
shoes I've done stuff like that I mean
we had a roof leaking when Sharon and I
went broke and went into bankruptcy and
I wasn't borrowing money anymore and I
would I had to borrow six thousand
dollars to put a roof on and I went and
got some of that uh
a tar stuff at the at the uh and spread
it on the roof it looked awful but it
quit leaking yeah until I could save up
to six thousand dollars now you might be
a redneck if right John but um but you
know you might be a redneck if you're
pumping your septic tank every three
weeks but hey we're saving up our money
and then I'm if and then if I'm you I'm
picking up extra jobs and working like
crazy because I got to buy some fill
lines
yes sir because you can't sell my house
yeah you can't sell it
right and that's been my problem I would
love to just sell and get out from under
it but now I'll get way less yeah you'll
get wet less than you paid for it you
thought you got it at a deal because you
can't get a health letter and nobody can
get a mortgage without a health letter
right yes sir and so you know if they
want to get a standard mortgage any kind
of standard conforming mortgage they're
going to they're going to require Health
Department later saying it's functional
on a septic system so yeah you got to
fix it so that's what I'm gonna do I'm
gonna work like a crazy man you got
anything you can sell
um a couple things yes sir I've sold a
couple things I've cut the TV out and
all kinds of good stuff trying to save
money I mean you don't have you don't
have a ten thousand dollar boat sitting
in the backyard
no sir I have zero dead I have a 25 year
old truck that I'm still puttering along
in I really don't have anything worth a
lot okay but you pay cash for the house
no sir the house is the only thing that
I only debt that I have how did you get
the loan
um I got the loan it was uh
it was at auction and so
um I was able to work with a small
mortgage company to get the loan
and it did not require inspection
because it was at auction yeah and
they're charging you an interest rate in
excess of seven percent
yes sir 6.99 what
is 6.99 yes oh it is seven okay that's
not bad I'm surprised okay I thought you
were getting gig I figured they had you
at 12. okay
um good that's good news all right John
this is going to be tough just roll up
so call the guy you may have to pay go
with a guy that's a little bit more
expensive but can give you a phased
program and we'll put in how many field
lines we got to do is are they saying
three what are they saying
uh I think it's supposed to have four on
it okay and none of them are functioning
none it's all either the cast iron or
it's the old terracotta yeah you may
have to do uh one at a time or you may
have to do two at a time
and get somebody to work with you on
that and
you know if you've got a buddy that's
got a backhoe
oh yeah yeah absolutely well maybe you
can get him to uh to get the septic guy
to let you do the digging and you you
don't have your buddy for a six pack of
beer dig the holes uh clean the lines
out and then the septic eye comes in and
that saves you that much money that's a
good buddy that's that's a great idea
yeah that might save you five grand
right there and just tell the septic you
know this guy just he needs to help you
out and then you're going to give him
you're going to tell everybody that you
know that ever needs any help in that
world that he's the guy because he took
care of you you know
absolutely it'd be good business for him
and yeah partner up with your backhoe
buddy and let's see if we can't get a
couple of these done for 10 grand get it
functioning and then add the other two
to get the luxury part of it working but
yeah it's a thing it's a thing
um we were building we're building a a
an event barn and we got into solid
freaking rock on stinking septic and
I've got so much money and that's
yeah we just
chisel and rock for days it went on for
days is awful that is awesome
horrible thing but yeah that's uh
now note to self this is what happens
when people talk about uh I'm gonna buy
foreclosures because I saw it I saw it
on Tick Tock yes and when you buy a
foreclosure at the courthouse steps you
know what you bought
as is where it is you don't know what it
is you might not have even been inside
the house and you're going there and
find out there are no pipes because they
used to be copper and the guys in the
neighborhood thought the copper belonged
to them and they took the copper down to
the supply place I mean down to the uh
salvage place and got some copper prices
for it and now you got no Plumbing in
the entire house I did that I did that I
did that house had no Plumbing
pipes were gone I knew it oh okay I I
broke into the house I'll admit it
before the four before the bidding so I
bought it based on the fact they had no
Plumbing but the other guy
did not know that and started running
the bid up and I told him I said you
know it's got no pipes he said what do
you mean I said you haven't been in the
house and he said no I said there's no
Plumbing it's all gone he quit bidding
and I won the bid that's a crappy
problem to have Dave yeah I mean you
start buying these auctions it's bad
oh man get yourself in trouble Jade wash
off good show today
well done Austin Ben James Zack and
Andrew the booth dudes in the booth
making this show happen I'm Dave Ramsey
your host we'll be back with you before
you know it in the meantime remember
there's ultimately only one way to
financial peace and that's to walk daily
with the Prince of Peace Christ Jesus
[Music]
jade look if you like what you heard in
this episode and want to know more about
getting started on the Ramsay baby steps
go to ramsesolutions.com and click the
get started button we'll help you figure
out the best next step for you based on
your specific situation that's
ramseysolutions.com and click get
started
[Music]